people think that if you're kind you get  walked over and i think that is  absolutely asinine i think that a lot of  people who claim they're being walked  all over are actually just trying to  manipulate situations i'm kind as [ __ ]  none of you are walking over me actual  kindness means giving without  expectation and i believe in business  what is very clear to me is people think  kindness and they use kindness but what  it really is is a slight version of  manipulation you're doing something with  thinking something else is gonna happen  and it's all good it's nice to maybe  think but don't confuse that with  kindness that's called strategy  don't say you're kind say you're  throwing out reels and trying to hope it  returns own what it actually is